she might not look it now
but jess the springer spaniel is a
victim of the pandemic
she's been stolen twice probably for
breeding
how are you hey she's good the pandemic
has driven up the price of puppies
so many of us want a covered companion
the male dogs get dumped and
any unspayed female dogs get kept
everybody wants a puppy in lockdown and
people are being less and less careful
about where they buy them from the
family's other dog tigg
is still in the hands of her thieves
they've demanded a ransom
not only were they trying to get money
out of me they were ringing up they were
getting little children to ring me up
and adults were coaching them in the
background
to play with my emotions and get me in a
more highly stressed state which was
really
despicable it sounds like organized
crime it is organised crime there's no
two ways about it
police say dog theft has become hugely
lucrative for crime gangs
in the pandemic the price of some
puppies has quadrupled
to more than two thousand pounds
organized crime groups adapt
they're crying to any markets and this
is a market that's grown the demand has
grown
so i think they see it as an opportunity
to make money
so that's where there's been a an
increase in the test of dogs
campaigners insist dog thieves are
treated too leniently
under the law a pet is treated as
property
they're not classed as animals and
therefore
the penalty for stealing
a dog is exactly the same as stealing
your mobile phone
it's just seen as a petty crime there's
nothing petty about stealing
a person's loved pet
it's three months since tig was stolen
what do you think is happening to her
now
i think unfortunately tig like a lot of
female dogs has been taken
so that she can be bred for puppies
and the horrible thing about that is
that they don't get
proper veterinary care they don't look
after these dogs they rinse them for as
many litters of puppies as they can
because all they see them is pound signs
the government said it was concerned at
a rise in pet theft
and took the issue very seriously it
understood
the pain and distress it caused
martin brunt sky news south london